[Music]
and
okay we'll go a4
um oh my god alexander so we got a hype
train there we go
you guys want to bribe me i see uh this
is the first time that we're facing i
think anything other than e5
in the five-minute speed run in the
five-minute speed run we faced this
actually quite a few times and so i
outlined
some of them that you know the ways we
can play against this
and my favorite setup here for white
well first of all let's get this
developing move out of the way
is the sort of english attack idea
now you can play knight f3 you can
develop normally
okay so e6 is a different setup e6 is
the hippo
i think or whatever it's called not the
hippo it's this weird setup where the
knight comes out to e7
and this i would recommend that you
tackle immediately
ferocious gesture now if you think about
it positionally the problem with the
movie 6
is that it creates a ton of dark square
weaknesses around the king's side
and when we when a complex of weakness
is created in this way
um oftentimes the way to exploit it is
by
opening up the position creating more
points of tension
and the way to do that as
and this is a move which everybody has
seen you've seen me play it too
in many of these positions that is the
early h4
now i'm not asking you guys to find this
move because it is
it requires a you know good amount of
experience in this position
um to understand why h4 is good okay so
he goes d5
now e5 would close down the center and
there's no need to close down the center
given that he's got all these weak
squares so how should we respond to this
if we don't want to close down this one
we don't want to take and we don't want
to open up his bishop that would be
foolish and i will explain
more in depth after the game because
these things can be a little bit hard to
formulate knight f3 is correct
um for for for your information
so the abbreviation for knight is
actually n um and the abbreviation for
king is k that's just the convention
and now we go h5 and now you guys should
begin to see why this is actually so
good
there's actually two main ideas to move
h5
the first is in mostly in the event that
he castles
we reserve the right to take on g6 and
open up the h file and checkmate
now in the event that he doesn't castle
and let's take back
we have cooked up a massive massive
threat which is what and particularly he
set the table for this threat let's hope
that we have a chance to deliver this
that threat is well what were we
threatening here
dark squares dark square dark squares we
know that this is the main weak
dark square boom bishop goes back
checkmate 400 thank you now what's the
first thing that we do the first thing
that we do is we notice that the knight
is attacked so we need to move the
knight right
no we asked the same shingling question
what happens if i do it anyway and this
is obviously very simple
we go h6 anyway counter-attacking the
bishop his position just
is completely in ruins
but but i'm you know 500 bits i'm
ishikibu and we got level two
holy smokes oh and now this is not made
oh man but we're gonna have something
very nice here
we're gonna have something really nice
here let me think actually for a second
okay we got four minutes to make him
until the server resets
so the obvious move is bishop g5
defending
defending the knight but we don't need
to do that
we don't need to do that we can actually
go 95 immediately
uh luring his king to g to f6
and the reason i go for this so
confidently is that his king is no
squares i i just
this isn't purely i don't know how to
put this other than this is intuitive
this is completely intuitive and now
here's the bamboo stick move
when and i've told this to you before
you got a situation where the king is
out of squares
you need to look at them from which
squares can you deliver checkmate
that is the key question that's how you
should formulate this and if you think
about it that way there's really only
one square
that square is g5 if g5 were to be
protected
then bishop g5 would be made so
we don't need to go queen h5 we don't
need to sacrifice
try to set up an idea where you prepare
to get a piece to g5 yes
queen d2 and it looks ugly this looks uh
like that's
that's all you're gonna do but in a
sense i think that's a very elegant move
you're just building a battery
and slamming the queen onto g5 and that
is checkmate
and i actually think that's the best
move i'm not sure
the alternative method would have been
to actually give a check anyway
lure the king to g5 now we're two pieces
down but now we can collect the queen
that would also be complete
winning although not checkmate simple
and
strong so
that's the danger of playing these kinds
of openings you know when they're
properly met
they weaken a lot of squares so h4 right
now
a lot of people had their heads in the
right place some people suggested e5
i like that you guys were thinking about
this move
because it's you know you're trying to
secure control over the score but this
is premature
because white is also not developed and
what can black do in a position like
this
what what can black do to contest
white's control now of these squares
all right d6 is right
yeah or c5
but c5 is not good because it we can oh
look at this square
remember what i always say about playing
e6 and g6 in the sicilian that's the
same effect
you want to go d6 here here you want to
get rid of this pawn
yeah like i can play f4 but then the
bishop can't really about black and go
97 black is okay here
so for that reason we're going from the
side of the board h4
and this is what i would categorize as a
provocative move
okay this is definitely a provocative
move
and a provocative move isn't like a
daring move necessarily in the context
of chess it's a move that tries to
provoke weaknesses
in one of several ways no matter what
black does if black plays h5
then what square does this weaken and
what can occupy that square
no it's not really theory i mean what
our opponent played isn't really a
theoretical line
yeah bishop g5 look at that beautiful
stronghold and now you can play e5 and
94 that's quite a bit stronger
if he plays h6 then there's a very
common idea here where you go h5
g5 and now f4 blasting open the king's
side
you'll see this all the time in these
types of positions this is also bad
our opponent decided to allow it after
knight f3 97
and now the double idea of going h6 and
hg is simply devastating
there's black just is isn't able to
contain all of the weaknesses in his
position
all right um what if uh what if f6 oh
but now look at these squares now we
just drop the bishop back
now we just drop the bishop back and we
can play bishop d3 and then later e5
this is a really really good i mean this
is basically winning positionally
all right so this pawn on h5
can do two things you can go to h6
dislodging the bishop from g7
and in an eventual attempt to get let's
say a knight to f6 or a bishop to f6
alternatively um in the event of black
castles we can play hg and open the h
file and try to check madame down that
file
all right so d e 94 f5 h6 counter
attacking the bishop
boom boom and queen d2 is the absolute
crusher
and that is the best move in fact that
is the only move that wins in a
clear-cut fashion i just checked the
computer the only one
because there's simply no stopping queen
g5 with checkmate you can stave it off
with this
that does not help because now bishop g5
is the main threat
okay um how should black react to h4
well
i i guess the lesser evil is probably to
go h5 i think that
this is probably the lesser evil
although this kind of position is
incredibly nasty it's still pretty much
defensible and quite solid
after our opponent allowed h5 i think
he's essentially losing there
and yes i would go so far as to say
losing
11 playing caught 050 cat
and let's go to cairo
so yeah so we've been encountering this
line
um at several junctures
in uh in our in our early speed run
career
there's um there are several ways that
we can tackle this
the sort of the karo khan way to do this
is to do what what's the karo khan
response to e5
so the karaoke move is bishop f5 now the
funny thing is and he probably doesn't
intend this
but in response to bishop f5 there's a
very nasty move
knight to d4 and i'll talk about this
after the game
so it's worth switching up the move
order here a little bit
in order to stop him from playing knight
d4
by making a move that we often also make
in the karo khan obviously which is c5
i'll talk a little bit more about the
details but trust me knight t4 is
the super nasty idea that uh that he may
or may not
uh know so
not a dangerous move we can cover this
check in a variety of ways there's no
reason not to play knight c6
let's develop normally he's probably
going to take it a lot of people
at this level still fall in love with
double pawns
but you know my position on these kinds
of pawn structure deficiencies
we save a tempo he moves his bishop
twice
and i like the two bishops i like the
fact that his pawn e5 is weak
i'm not worried about bishop c6 in the
in the slightest
the slightest okay knight c3
so in what order shall we develop our
pieces so e6
is fine but that would block in the
bishop on c8
um so we turn to the bishop on c where
should we put it
where should we put it so bishop f5 is
of course so possible
but you have to be very flexible when it
comes to development
and always consider if there might not
be
something better that usually doesn't
exist if you look at that here
you'll notice that bishop g4 exists and
i think bishop g4 is quite a bit more
active
bishop h5 keeping the pin alive g4
bishop g6
and he goes d4 so he's created a lot of
weaknesses
on his king side and now he plays d4
he's not playing this badly and he's
hoping
for c takes d4 because then
uh he will play knight takes c4 and
he'll pile up on the knight on c6 how
should we respond to d4
how should we respond to d4 what's up
men
yeah just e6 e6 is like again super
typical caro khan move
preparing to recapture with the bishop
trading on our own terms bishop g5
not dangerous now the knee-jerk reaction
i think for most people
is probably to go bishop e7 here
but there i think there's a better move
oh thank you thank you man i think
there's a better move and
some of you are noticing that better
move the screen bc it's just very nasty
because we're applying pressure on the
pawn we're applying pressure on the
bishop we're not attacking either
actually
but there's a sense in which white's
position is kind of close already to
collapsing and
okay we have you guys ready for a
a somewhat risky but somewhat five head
move
so when the moment that he played g4 i
out of the corner of my eye i made a
mental note to myself to check this move
and well first of all i'll give you guys
a chance to find this move
because what did i notice when he played
g4 what i noticed is that this knight on
f3 no longer has a defender
not only does this knight no longer have
a defender but the pawn on d4 is also
very poorly defended
it would be very nice if white had a
pawn on c3 as he usually does in these
situations
now you might be looking at this and
saying wait a second i have three
three attackers there's only two
defenders why can't i just take on d4
of course the complicating factor is the
pin what we can try to do
is play bishop e4 attacking the knight
and if he takes the bishop i take with
the pawn the knight is dislodged
this bishop is also going to be
undefended if he takes my bishop on e4
and in order to deal with this
successfully okay so queen e3
now that defends the night but it
doesn't solve the underlying issue why
did we play bishop b4
not just to win this night but also to
um wait actually we have something
better
wait a minute i was going to take the
knight but now that i look at this a
little bit more carefully
what can we do here
yeah fork but that's a bit of a
misleading
uh notion right because the point of
this isn't that it's a fork he can still
play knight takes d4 as he could before
but here
there is a rook on h1 that hangs that
line is more complicated than it looks
and we'll talk about it after the game
but the bottom yeah exactly
but i had an idea there a6 so we'll talk
about it
now he's panicked and gone queen to d2
which of these two knights should we
take
um and we can actually take either
that's the funny thing
but if you wanted to play this sort of
more in the most uh let's just say
precise man okay he just resigns
um because we can take either knight we
would take
the knight on f3 i would take the knight
on f3 although we could take the knight
on c3
because after bishop c6 bc queen takes
c3 defends the knight
boom goes the dynamite that pins the
queen
thank you slunt okay
so yeah so here
bishop f5 is possible but i was a little
bit fearful of this move
and if you drop your bishop back
and now that i i'm checking with the
computer this is actually good for black
but i i misremembered this but what move
uh do you think that i was afraid of
here
uh from white's perspective
yeah i don't like allowing a move like
this e6 right
h4 is is is is never dangerous h4 is
always possible
but h4 can always be met with h6 the
move that i never like
to face is e6 because this pawn is sort
of very radioactive
and it it
i mean white wants to take on f7 and
weaken black's king's side
if you take on e6 then this knight jumps
to e6 then it can take nf8 and black
loses castling rights
but the reason that this is actually not
dangerous
and computers are a lot better at this
than humans computers are
very good at ignoring stuff humans are
very bad typically at ignoring stuff and
so the computer's
recommendation here is to pretend that
nothing's happening and just simply go
knight f6
that is very very instructive because
here's what the computer is saying it's
not saying anything
what it's essentially saying is after e
takes f7 bishop takes f7
it is true that black's king's side has
been damaged a little bit
it is also true that white has not
developed any of his pieces other than
his knight
this knight is susceptible to the move
e5 with tempo
in addition if you've watched my white
games you'll know
that the opening of the f-file can
actually be good for black in the long
run
when black castles so this
notion of not doing anything ignoring
uh almost what seems to be the threat is
very instructive because there actually
is no threat
if there's an illusion of a threat but
there is no threat and
just developing normally uh is often the
solution to these things
okay um
yeah so instead we decided to go c5
this should be five check what if i
doesn't go f7
um well how do you propose why play
and if white like develops his bishop
for example
then i could essentially go queen d6 and
compel him
now to take on f7 in kind of a soft
banner without doing anything crazy
and then go bishop f7 and then go e5 etc
all right so
c5 bishop b5 knight c6
knight c3 which is fine bishop g4
and here i think that he played fine h3
is good
g4 is good and here he missed
i think a chance to get an advantage and
funnily enough
in a effort to prevent e6
i have actually allowed him to play e6
in a much better version
the movie 6 gives white a very big
initiative
this is super instructive the point of
e6
is completely different than why it was
made earlier
so here the point of e6 is not
necessarily to ruin
white's king side it's a positional pawn
sacrifice
what do you gain in return for this pawn
sacrifice other than the obvious
fact that black has doubled pawns who
can explain that to me and who can tell
me
white's next move
yeah so first of all this is super nasty
second of all look at this bishop it's
completely stuck
black can't develop the rest of his king
side and already the center is opened up
white can slam d4 onto the board and
this comes out this is actually quite a
thematic idea you'll see this
in some lines this is very very nasty
and uh this kind of positional sacrifice
to give up upon in order to delay the
development of
an entire flank can be among the most
dangerous
uh that you can find in general so
bishop g
no i think bishop h5 was it was an
inaccuracy i should have taken
and got e6 in this case i should have
taken
um okay but what if black just ignores
the pawn again
well um if you ignore the pawn again
then the move knight e5 and maybe i
should but knight e5 seems to come with
even greater effect than before
this is just as unpleasant whether or
not you take on e6
okay so d46
and at this point things start to
deteriorate for him i think that this is
the last moment
yeah bishop before is correct actually
that is correct
so i just wanted to show that after
bishop e4 if he goes knight takes c4
d takes c4 his position collapses
because after bishop takes c6 we can do
something
really really cool black is winning in
this position
what should we take the bishop with and
what is the idea of that capture
yeah very nice bread first queen takes
e6 we notice the x-ray the standoff with
the rook
after the knight moves we have the move
e3 winning the game of the spot
because the rook is lost so that's why i
always
advocate for you to observe these
standoffs like when you see two pieces
queen and rook on the same diagonal
stuff like that needs to be noticed
because it can lead unexpectedly to
these kinds of tactics okay
so queen e3 cd he went back i mean at
this point
the situation is dire he should have
tried
is this and then this
and the point of this is that if we just
take the knight
thinking ah well he can't take my pawn
because it's defended but first white
takes the queen
then he takes the pawn and he forks the
rook and so white
black has to be very very precise here
in this position in order not to avoid
getting
in order to avoid getting checkmated
literally white is threading checkmate
but black can play a6 after bishop a4
black and play b5 and
shut down this bishop and then black is
up in exchange
so this line was more complicated than
it looked i saw a6 in my head
so i relied on this but uh this kind of
stuff
needed to be calculated after queen e2
the game is over if we just take this
knight and then take that knight white
loses all of his pieces
so that was that game um
definitely more stuff to discuss in the
car con and we'll discuss
a lot of it because that'll be probably
my main opening you know
for the next 100 200 points okay
all right guys we'll call it a night
i'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you